videz votre esprit soyez comme de l'eau maintenant l'
eau peut couler ou s'écraser Bruce Lee
est une icône mondiale du combat c'était du fer
37 livres c'est l'arme si quelqu'un dit que
je ne peux pas regarder un film de Bruce Lee dont je
ne peux pas parler je  était comme l'Elvis des
arts martiaux tout ce que personnellement vous
ne pensez pas au karaté asiatique ouais
vous pensez à un héritage les mouvements que
vous pourriez faire quand vous vous
demandiez s'ils accéléraient la caméra il y a
des trucs sympas juste là Bruce Lee
était  comme un super héros de la
communauté asiatique farouchement pop faisant tout le
jay-z Tiger Kobe Jordan ils ont tous
le même esprit au début je n'avais
aucune intention que ce que je pratiquais
ce que je pratique encore maintenant mènerait
à cela vous obtenez  mysticisme vous pouvez hyper
masculinité ce gars est comme en donner un
du genre et extrêmement attrayant il a
mis des boules sur les hommes chinois c'est l'ambiance
qui m'a le mieux appris habituellement c'est de toujours
apporter bébé Qui je suis
toi